[Música]
[Aplausos]
aquí
es un placer presentarme ante ustedes
para hablar de un tema que a veces no
nos parece como tan indispensable
hacerlo visible
pero bueno vamos a tratarlo y tratarlo
de una manera en mí
que nos van sentir con un compromiso
social de poder ayudar a otras personas
y lo que queremos todos al final de
cuentas es vivir en paz
caminar tranquilas caminar tranquilos
conocer
tenemos cerca y poder saludarles todos
los días
es porque nos gustaría mucho que pasara
en la sociedad en la que vivimos
es un reloj pero no es cualquier reloj
es un reloj en el que ahorita en este
momento aproximadamente 18 familias
están teniendo un problema y están
teniendo una circunstancia muy difícil
donde están enfrentando hechos de
violencia
una familia que está con esa posibilidad
y ese riesgo de que se pudiera ver
siempre
pero que están niños y niñas
adolescentes también que pudieran tener
ese impacto indirecto
este no es un halo cualquiera pero
también a veces pensamos nosotras todas
las personas que las casas nuestra casa
es el espacio más seguro que es en dónde
podemos llegar
podemos estar tranquilas podemos
relajarnos pero a veces más así
hay una jovencita de 20 años de edad que
se llama eric a erick a
tuvo que vivir violencia a manos de su
papá es un papá
siempre le decía que ponerse le decía
cómo arreglarse qué amistades tener a
dónde ir qué comer qué no comer y un día
pues erika ha estado ya de 20 años
ingresó a la universidad y empezó a
tener una relación de noviazgo su
paciente y su papá reaccionó de una
manera que quizá no fue la más apropiada
fue a la universidad volvió al novio y
sacó a golpes a su hija erika tenía una
situación muy compleja que hago que digo
es que es mi papá y él les cuenta la
historia de una persona joven pero
también hay personas de mi edad o quizá
más grandes que yo o más jóvenes que yo
que también les puede ocurrir lo mismo y
que están en una situación muy
complicada muy difícil porque a quien
pudiera denunciar es una persona que ama
no es una persona por la que hay afecto
por la que el cariño por la que tienen a
la mejor la idea de un proyecto de vida
y es una situación todavía mucho más
y más difícil cuando escuchamos familia
por supuesto que pensamos que es ese
lugar esas personas que nos aman que
podemos estar más seguras y tranquilas
todas las personas pero a veces no es
así
y tenemos esa dificultad de poder
empezar a pensar qué hacemos dónde vamos
o con quién acudimos o si pudiéramos
tener una situación menos 105 y en este
espacio es también espacio de lo público
verdad también tenemos dificultades la
calle también se convierte en un
problema difícil en una situación
complicada y les voy a contar otra
historia y esta historia es de una
jovencita yo al salir de mi casa como
todos los días en la mañana aprisa y
corriendo porque se nos hace tarde me
encuentro en una situación en donde de
pronto llega una de mis familiares
la fuerte encuentro la escena de
familiar queriendo entrar pero también
de una joven que quiere atravesar la
calle con una cara de angustia
como de terror yo trato de decirle que
pasa que cruzó la calle nos subimos a la
banca a la banqueta no puede articular
palabra
qué pasa que se tranquilice que si tiene
un teléfono que me permita para poderme
comunicar con alguien de su familia me
muestra su teléfono y lo veo que está
roto se le cayó y le invitó a que se
tomara aire respire y me empiece a
contar una reunión esta mañana siguiendo
tienen dos personas dos hombres que me
están siguiendo miréis que de vuelta por
aquí me persiguieron y di vuelta por
acta divina la camioneta trate de que se
tranquilizara el marco a su mamá su mamá
le comentó que en ese momento llegaría
yo dije bueno que amos la abrazó le
trate de guardar distancia porque no
está fácil también que abracemos a
cualquier persona en la calle y en ese
momento posteriormente
pero una camioneta ya voltea se angustia
y sed están ellos
le dije espérame tantito me fui a la
camioneta le pregunté a los hombres que
deseaban y me dicen estamos buscando la
calle tal el número tal no está más la
calle y se marcha
es lo que pasa
que queremos nosotros sentirnos
tranquilas y tranquilos de caminar por
la calle
pero además
lo que necesitamos es que la calle
generalmente es un espacio seguro en
otros tiempos ahorita no dejamos de
salir a las personas más pequeñitas de
nuestra familia a que estén ahí
y salir en bicicleta estamos vigilando o
cuidando la calle no es un espacio
seguro tampoco pero y entonces qué pasa
tampoco la casa tampoco nuestro hogar se
está convirtiendo en un espacio seguro y
cuando nosotras escuchamos y todas las
personas podemos escuchar estas
historias que atendemos todos los días
yo tengo ya muchos años trabajando con
personas que han vivido violencia tanto
en mujeres hombres niñas niños
adolescentes personas mayores y lo que
hemos visto
no necesitan ser escuchadas las personas
en un primer momento necesitan contar su
historia no todas algunas otras son muy
reservadas si no quieres pero
generalmente necesitan contar su
historia y que las escuchemos que además
en ese momento de crisis reciban
información que después de ayudar a
tomar decisiones y que esas decisiones
necesitan estar
tomándose de manera a veces muy rápida
qué hacer si hay un hombre que las está
persiguiendo denuncian o no denuncia y
es parte de los relatos que yo hoy les
estoy contando aquí bueno podríamos
pasarnos muchos más tiempo con tantos
relatos de este orden pero lo que quiero
hoy poner aquí para que ustedes las
manos vayamos con esa reflexión un
poquito es que las personas tenemos
necesidades de información también
necesitamos estar informadas para
qué hacer adónde acudir saber si hay
algún tipo de servicio gratuito o no
entiende puede ayudar a algunas
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
y en si hay el estado el propio estado
que me puede ayudar no todas estas
situaciones tanto en los casos que les
he comentado
la chica jovencita universitaria y la
otra jovencita que le ocurrió este
incidente en la calle lo que tienen en
común es la violencia y son situaciones
que de repente a nosotros nos parece que
no pasa porque es como que siempre le
pasa a la otra y nos puede estar pasando
pero no las identificamos porque hay
violencias que lo llamamos
microviolencias también sea pequeñita
chiquitita que no se nota que apenas él
percibe pero que está impuesta y que es
quien la ejerce hacia mí pues es una
persona que tenemos y que amamos y que
de pronto nos resulta un poquito difícil
pero si pudiéramos decir que bien de las
personas que estamos en este espacio
hemos vivido la violencia
podríamos pues casi todas levantar la
mano hombres y mujeres niñas y niños
personas mayores y personas más jóvenes
hemos vivido esta situación de violencia
y necesitamos tener la información
adecuada para saber qué actuar lo que
nos interesa mucho es que ese espacio
privado que es la casa y el espacio
público
sea tranquilo este ejercicio que estamos
hoy haciendo de escucharnos a mí me da
mucho gusto saber que hay muchas otras
personas que están trabajando en
proyectos para hacer todas llevarnos
bien ser iguales buscar un san luís
potosí más atractivo y más bonito para
poder ser felices que es al final lo que
queremos este calendario no es cualquier
calendario es un calendario en el eje de
sangre es un calendario en que esas
situaciones de violencia que no se
pueden quizás llegar a un límite y
establecer algunos otros criterios pues
llegan a una situación fatal y es que en
san luís potosí una mujer muere cada
semana por hechos relacionados por su
condición de ser mujeres y son
estadísticas recientes al mes de octubre
qué hacer si nos gustaría apoyar a las
personas que se acercan con nosotras que
no existen bueno mira yo tengo este
problema lo mejor es poderles escuchar
primero porque necesitan que las
necesitan ser escuchadas pero además de
ser escuchadas necesitan que les demos
información si no tenemos información
para darles busquemos quién se las pueda
dar para que tengan una mejor manera
para tomar decisiones pero también hay
que ver si tienen alguna necesidad si
necesitan a veces salen corriendo de su
casa no traen dinero ni para el camión
para comer para una blusa zapatos
etcétera y después buscarles apoyo
porque a veces nosotros no podemos ser
más que ese es su oído que las quiere
escuchar y que les quiere apoyar de
alguna manera este calendario es muy
grave el que les mostré pero yo lo
quiero poner hoy aquí y también el reloj
porque lo que me interesa es que nos
veamos como iguales que nos veamos con
esas different
biológicas que tenemos que somos
personas y que somos iguales pero dentro
de esa misma igualdad que nosotros
tenemos a mí me daría mucha tristeza que
por mi sola condición de ser mujer diera
a la calle y un hombre me hiciera miedo
y aunque muchos hombres están en la
misma situación que sólo por su
condición de ser hombres los vean y les
tengan miedo no podemos permitir eso no
nos podemos permitir que en mis mujeres
tengan miedo de hombre ni los hombres
tengan miedo de nosotras necesitamos
buscar un espacio que nos ayude a lograr
una convivencia plena justa equitativa
solidaria y eso es lo que yo hoy les
vengo a decir necesitamos ofrecer esa
escucha para que las personas que tienen
una dificultad un problema y que si yo
no les puedo ayudar yo busque quien les
pueda atender para que les resuelva
puedan resolver sus problemas pero
era consciente plena solidario y hoy les
invito a que pudiéramos con nuestra
propia forma de decir las cosas el
discurso es muy importante en el
discurso hay muchas palabras que
encerramos normalmente no hablamos más
que en masculino o en femenino
yo hoy trate de hacer y casi siempre lo
intento hacer y lo ocupó todos los días
de mi vida de tener un lenguaje neutral
en ese lenguaje neutral es tratar de
hablarnos como personas como seres
humanos
realizarnos a apoyarlos qué es lo que
más nos interesa que tengamos un
sandwich cada vez más tranquilo más
solidario y que podamos vivir
completamente con necesitaran
me da muchas mucho gusto estar aquí les
agrade
sí
de expansión